they managed to escape the horror but
are still suffering from the trauma of
their days trapped in mariopol
surrounded by the russian army
i can't find the words to describe that
horror that we experienced
we saw how much the city was destroyed
my son was running under rocket fire to
collect water we collected snow
boiled it to drink
65 year old irina peregristova and her
husband sergey spent 20 days hiding in a
basement from the raging battle above
they fled here to zaparica taken in by
their friend constantine
we had only two liters of water we drank
water not meant for drinking we boiled
it on the fire and drank it we only had
potatoes to eat
they are not alone in this ordeal
over four hundred thousand call the city
home
irena recalls the moment they made it
out
it was a miracle
when we heard that explosion in the
center of marijuana close to the drama
theater we jumped into the car and ran
away from there
we didn't really had a route we were
just trying to get out
and then we happened by chance to join
the convoy of cars
they can't believe that this has
happened to them from a people they once
felt they knew
many of our people have been married and
stayed in russia
we maintained relations we have grew up
here it's our country our motherland
we always thought that russia is strong
component but not an enemy
not an enemy
why
just because family relations smooth
those political conflicts we talked to
each other our relatives came to us we
spent some time at the sea
and when the war broke out we just
couldn't understand that it could be a
war between two brothers
they can never go back
the pain is too much
her mother died when their house was
bombed
i want to tell you something
and that house which was bombed we left
my 86 year old mother are you prosthetic
lipstick we just weren't able to carry
her out
[Laughter]
ninety percent of mariupal is destroyed
there is nothing more there
we don't have a place to go back to
they can now only wait
the future
hoping the war doesn't follow them here
al jazeera zappa richard